mr uh jim irsay ceo and owner of the
indianapolis colts joins us now
mr say how are you doing sir hey ryan
i'm doing well thank you you make me
smile to
to think about my old friend hunter uh
it's been
you know 2005 since we lost him and and
uh
time flies by awfully quick but uh but
it's um
it's a a joy to be out here talking
about
hunter's legacy some and and certainly
um
really uh uh you know thrilled to be on
with you you know we haven't talked uh
much through the years
and um you know i'm just uh i'm
just really excited how great you're
doing and a big fan
of of um you know of your life and where
you are at this point uh
it just shows um a lot of courage and i
i'm just really excited
uh to be here because you know we are
all part of
history back there in 1998 and it and it
was a very interesting time um
so when you got this letter from hunter
s thompson
who is talking to you blatantly about a
couple guys that you were invested
what what what did you think when you
received this letter and what were you
thinking in terms of were you allowing
the guys that you hired bill polian and
jim moore
and everybody to make the decision or
was hey was i just that big
flashy strong guy that wasn't going to
get crushed by sap freaks
that you wanted as well well i tell you
you know with hunter
we were really good friends and and we
had
many many conversations um uh
and laughs and and i always tried to
kind of catch hunter
when when he was uh you know kind of on
the straight narrow which
which is kind of hard to catch sometimes
but uh i
i would because he's one of the most
brilliant men uh
i've ever met and and being a writer
myself dylan thomas
and hunter are my two favorite writers
ever
and um you know going back to that time
i i tell you
you know i can unequivocally say it was
a very very close call
um a lot of people in the league
i won't say it's 50 50 but it could have
been
60 40 one way or the other um
it it was a very difficult decision bill
pauline and i
talked and had many many long talks
and in the end um made the decision
towards peyton but it was really a close
call
i had um a long long trusted individual
who'd been in the nfl a long time just
hours before the draft and said
he said i'd take ryan you know um over
peyton but but in the end bill and i
um just just you know we we just kind of
felt
that that um you know that that we are
going to be
um better off um picking peyton but
again it was it was very close
and people forget how close it was back
then
because really it was close to flipping
a coin close well you know what i think
he i think he made
the right choice and maybe maybe colonel
depp had something to to say about it
too and who was cc'd there at the end of
that letter um
um well no question i tell you can i uh
i i want to just uh real briefly you
know
read something that that hunter wrote me
um in may 5th of 1997
right before that letter and uh on an
original copy of
fear and lothi on the campaign trail he
scrawled out
um this this barrage of words at me
and uh cam and crow the great uh
director in hollywood
um and uh you know jerry maguire
when when cameron read it he said man
that's some of hunter's best work but
but what i'm gonna do now is um i i have
um
uh this this to read and this is hunter
um uh may 5th 1997
um scrolling some mad words at me
as he scrawled about uh you coming out
in the draft so
so here we go on on uh three
two one to jim irsay
the colts suck because you dissed the
whole concept of team or even
gang the colts act like a third world
transient
in a holding pen with just enough
whiskey and weirdness and talent to be
competitive but soon
they will start getting busted small
things at first but soon bigger and
faster and uglier
and your shame will be as the shame of
many of your days
which will be [ __ ] episodes full of
crooked cops
and wrongful dishonor that is what i see
in your future james
for yesterday you poor bastards
because you're too dumb to even fake a
team concept or even to say the word we
in public
that's why you can't have any fun
with the colts and you won't have any
fun with the browns
or the horse or the globetrotters be
careful james
your greed crazed outbursts are
beginning to rub off on people
oh wow how did you two how did you two
become
friends and how did you have this this
relationship there where he could just
just come talk to you like that oh you
know i tell you
uh a couple of guys you know cameron
crowe
i helped out on jerry maguire and and
cameron had had known hunter through the
years uh with the on at rolling stone
and everything and
and um and then doug brinkley
uh just a well-known great writer in
this country
um a lot of political biographies and
i'm seeing in a lot
doug was kind of like an understudy for
hunter and kind of
help hunter keep it together um you know
when hunter
you know wasn't that eager to pick up
the pin and work very much you know
and john wallace used to go up there and
uh
and uh you know i talked to john and
hunter be there
and it'd be all times of the night you
know with hunter he'd wake up
at like you know 5 30 in the afternoon
and go to sleep at like you know
8 or 8 30 you know mountain time so you
had to you know
if you couldn't sleep you could always
call up hunter uh
for some friendly advice or some fun uh
his schedule is like none other
but um i i tell you it was just so
hilarious
um just just because he he just loved
the nfl
so much um and you know
honestly ryan he was a a big-hearted guy
a grandfather
and um uh you know i i
i tried to talk to him some about about
getting sober and those sorts of things
but
you know it just he just didn't have
that interest in
you know it was heartbreaking um when
the suicide happened um
and everything you know anita's wife i
knew well and
um it's just tough you know he covered
hemingway's suicide in 59
as a young journalist and he had it set
in his mind that when
his body you know was given out too much
um that was gonna be that you know and
and i talked to him
the day before he committed suicide and
and uh
you know he just was different you know
he said you know i love you james
and he never talked like that you know
and i said man what are you talking
about
and um you know the next day you know it
it kind of happened and
and uh you know it was really really
painful because you know when you lose
someone
um to suicide you know
at first you're kind of pissed off right
you're
you're like damn it hunter you know he
was 67
in 2005 so you know now he'd be 83 years
old but
um but but he was he was something a one
of a kind no doubt in
and we had so many funny conversations
and
and boy he he loved the nfl and loved
football and
and um uh just an american icon just
really a brilliant man one of the three
or four smartest guys i ever met my life
the guy was
incredible and and uh um
you know it was a big loss when we when
we lost him
um but it was great uh you know the
impact he left with his writing um
is is just incredible and and uh miss
him to this day man
yeah i appreciate you sharing some of
that
um i told the story a little bit earlier
i think was three years ago i was in
indianapolis uh speaking at a
recovery event uh the healing place and
a friend of mine uh
reached uh across to me after the event
and said hey mr irsay and ryan balor
would love for you to come over to the
facility and
and say hi and see him on in the war
room on draft night and
uh i was just taken aback you know
for the longest time i looked at you
know my nfl career
is so toxic and once i left prison
and got sober and found this new way of
life
the relationships that i built and made
and i just want to tell you personally
that that night was
it was incredibly meaningful to me and
it's something i always look back to as
a
as a kind of a shining um beacon on on
where i've
where i've come from and where i'm going
well i mean that's so awesome i mean
like
darius leonard says and kick the stigma
psa that's been going around that we put
together you know
it's all right not to be all right right
and
and and you know you've helped so many
people
um just coming through what you've come
through you know you're
straight home and experience um it is
going to change
a lot of people's lives and you might be
able to help that that young quarterback
coming out of college at 22
and say hey um think a little bit before
you make some of those turns because you
might be you know in the wrong part of
town if you're not careful
and uh it's tough guys come out 22 years
old they're instant millionaires
um people say why is that tough that's
the luckiest thing in the world but
um you know if uh you know let an
alcoholic
win the lottery and you got trouble you
know it doesn't
you know it doesn't usually go well but
um
as you know uh you know you you know you
really
are are a blessing and and you're you're
here for a reason and god
um has a purpose for you and to see you
so strong
and doing so well um i i i mean it it's
just such a testament
to um what we have to do in this life
because it's really
you know to me it's about the spiritual
struggle because whether
it's alcohol or drugs or depression or
no matter what you go through
um it's you know as we say we're
we're not human beings having a
spiritual experience but we're spiritual
beings having a human experience yes sir
and um you know that that's really to me
that the biggest thing is we all
are faced with tough spiritual
crossroads and
and uh you know it breaks my heart
sometimes to see
humans judge humans because you know we
have no business judging you know i
leave that to a power i call god and
and you know my business is to love and
forgive you know and
and uh the rest um is in god's hands and
and so um you know it's it's an awesome
thing
you know to sit here in 2021 in march
and
and here you are here i am you're
hosting the show
uh you know looking so so strong and and
doing so well
it's it's incredible um
but uh you know we we really do
uh i know i do i try to reach out to all
our players that that have gone through
difficult times in in any way shape or
form
and you're always rooting for for things
to get better and
and uh um the work you're doing um
is tremendous ryan and and really um
i i you know just so proud to see how
awesome you're doing and and
we're all locked in that moment in 98 in
in nfl history because it really was one
of the greatest
draft years and moments ever and uh
you know god has its reasons why things
work out but
we're both here um happy and healthy on
this day
and that's certainly a testament to
amazing grace brother
it is it definitely is thank you for all
that uh i appreciate it so much hey uh
uh before we get you out of here
when when you know as an owner does word
get
back to you like the war room when when
bill paulian and jim moore and
all the scouts are in there and they're
they're talking about hey you know you
need to go with this leaf guy
and then there's another version of like
no we have to go with the manning
manning ones i mean how much of that
gets back to the owner
ultimately and when it was all said and
done did the manning troop did they turn
around and be like
hey i told you so i told you this was
the way it was supposed to go
well you know really you know for me
first of all
you know it's my 50th year in the league
you know so
i started in training camp in gold in
colorado
50 years ago johnny knight is nudging me
in
in the in the you know lunch room uh
saying move your ass son
and uh you know johnny united sat next
to me
and and the rest is history unfurling
but you know
before me as time went along so i you
know i started picking up
you know jock straps in the locker room
for five bucks a week and
and did every job in the organization
and you know was general manager
24 so um you know it's a little
different from
my perspective um uh when i hired bill
polian him and i were colleagues i mean
him and i and steve gutman and
george young are the ones who developed
the draft under
roselle's direction in the late 80s in
new york
um the cap i mean that that we see today
um and uh and so
with bill and i and and those sorts of
things you know
my thing is to be supportive because i
know how hard it is to be
a general manager and the pressures that
are on you
um and and really you know
peyton um not at all i mean you know
peyton's such a
tremendous guy obviously uh going
uh you know into the hall of fame this
august
and and uh you know i can't say enough
about
him and and just his humility and
his appreciation i mean look at um he
knows it's tough to play
quarterback in this league and to be a
big time college player
you know to be you know even drafted
much less drafted in the first round
much less drafted
in the first two picks i mean that's
just incredible
and um you know sometimes circumstances
happen where
it just doesn't work out that way and
that's just the way it is but
but he's always been incredible and and
and humble about it and
and uh you know because he knows how
hard he had to work
um you know to over come and to be great
like like he became so
definitely um it's it's it's awesome and
ironically also today ryan is um
the 50-year anniversary that
hunter s thompson sent in the polo
lounge
at the beverly hills hotel in los
angeles which i know well
uh and headed off to vegas for
um you know the famous fear and loading
in las vegas so
um it was a long time ago uh
um him and his counterpart are having a
pre-drink before they hit the road
um little did he know you know that uh
that he was gonna be um uh you know
sniffing ether halfway
like you said it was around barstow
where the when the drugs kicked in
the famous line in the book and and uh
you know that read is quite a a madness
uh
read a journey but it's it's really
great writing it more than anything it's
just
incredible the way hunter could turn you
know checking into a hotel
uh hunter turns it into you know a lion
country safari adventure i mean
you know he was just such a great writer
and and um
uh you know through it all um that's
what he's remembered as not
not the craziness and the drugs and
alcohol that all that stuff is just a
sideshow but
but but what a writer he was i mean one
of the greatest american writers ever
and that's how i'll always treasure and
remember him so much
yes sir yes sir you're listening to jim
irsay owner and ceo of the indianapolis
colts
mr irsay thank you for taking the time
today to talk about hunter to talk about
1998 and just uh continuing to be a
beacon for
for those who still struggle i
appreciate you a ton well thank you
and and thanks for having me ryan and
good luck with the show i'll read
big shoes to fill with rich cons yeah
i heard he just made a double bogey in
hawaii
well that wouldn't be a surprise thank
you jim
all right all right well take care and
god bless man
yes sir yes all right bye-bye bye now
jim merce that was incredible wasn't it
that was incredible
oh my gosh that was amazing all right
yeah this was this was rich's idea he he
called me yesterday out of the blue and
asked me you know it was how kind of you
said hey would you mind uh
you know what what do you think about
this idea if we had jeremy on to talk
about the hunter s thompson letter and
you know the 1998 draft and i said
great that'd be a great segment hey you
watched all the way to the end thanks
for that
watch more right here